so one of the things you spoke about
during the pandemic was keeping track of
our mental health and we touch them a
bit here how was your mind doing there
everything mine has been a roller
coaster yeah it's definitely been a
roller coaster and you know I've been
I've been very open and vocal about
growing up with mental health challenges
and that's a continuing you know issue
for many of us who struggle also the
notion that it's okay to not be okay
that's some of the messaging that Nami
the National Alliance on Mental Illness
tries to really spread the word about
you know I'm not gonna sugarcoat it it's
been incredibly taxing you know for many
of us especially those of us who
struggled before I'm an introvert by
nature which means I don't mind being on
my own and not really going out a lot
notion that that's being chosen for me
yeah the option has been ripped yeah I'm
really isolating and you know my tempers
been short my sleeps been weird you know
I started getting heartburn again like
just like all the stress things like but
those are those stress things for my
body and I'm also I was talking with a
girlfriend and like even even my lady
cycle has felt more emotional during the
quarantine like everything is heightened
and like my mom has a pinched nerve in
her back she's never had that before and
I said like we're all stressed with
living in masks we don't know what
tomorrow brings the news is insane the
country's falling apart it feels like
it's very stressful even for someone who
has zero history with mental health
stuff and for those of us who have OCD
like there's plenty of things to have
new obsessions and compulsions about it
I promise I know it's been it definitely
it's been a roller coaster I can't I
have suffered from depression and it's
like one of those things where I don't
do well and I'm an extrovert so this
like not seeing humans and not
interacting and I like really feed off
of people's energy and I you know and I
love the people that I've chosen or
surround myself with my life said yeah
I've definitely missed even like my glam
squad you know I don't miss glam I love
what they do but I don't miss the hour
of sitting there but I ma'am and I was
talking to them and I think all of us
are like that with with work and stuff
you can only like do so many zoo
meetings you know
yeah it only does so much and even
socializing it's just it's not the same
and like you have to use your voice
differently and you like worry what I
look like and I end up just like staring
at myself the whole time I'm like why do
I look like that that's not helpful
either
yeah I don't even do that I just never
look um that's my that's the key just
don't look
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going